the two likely Front Runners in the race
to become the UK's next prime minister
have held face-to-face talks on Saturday
neither Boris Johnson nor his former
Ally Rishi sunak though have officially
declared that they are running but both
say they do have the support of 100 MPS
which is the number needed to enter the
race so far only senior Cabinet member
penny mordant is officially running
let's go straight to Stephanie Decker
who is live for us in London this is a
roller coaster for story isn't it
Stephanie we have this late night
closed-door meeting between Rishi sunak
and Boris Johnson do we have any idea
what if anything came out of that
well as of this morning according to
some media reports uh Boris Johnson is
not backing down there was some
speculation that this meeting might be
about and of course this is between two
men who do not see ITI have quite a
turbulent relationship
um uh trying to figure out some deal
that might be best for the country and
for the party of course according to
their interests but Boris Johnson this
morning being quoted as saying that he's
not backing down that he is the only man
for the job that the country now needs
to be managed and that he's going to do
it and that he has the backing um again
we're waiting for confirmation of those
numbers from what we understand Rishi
sunak is the only one at the moment that
has over 100 nominations needed to be
put forward as a candidate but certainly
at this point in time it seems Boris
Johnson not backing down and there is
another question there are very stored
supporters of Boris Johnson who are
actually reporting supporting Rishi
sunak at this point saying the country
needs a new start also of course you
have a part of Elementary inquiry
hanging over Boris Johnson if he does
become Prime Minister this is something
that will continue if he is found guilty
this will cause all other constitutional
questions and a constitutional crisis
potentially all at a time when this
country needs someone to govern
immediately some people saying you know
it's interesting you have all this back
and forth within the conservative party
but no one is really talking about how
to get this country out of a severe
economic crisis when we talk about a
country we're talking about millions and
millions and millions of people who are
suffering on a daily basis just briefly
penny more than you said there she's the
only one who's thrown her hat into the
ring she seems to have the lowest amount
of nominations at the moment she did go
onto one of the main news channels this
morning where she was pressed as to what
her economic policies would be this is
of course the question of the day how
did you get this country out of Crisis
and she really refused to answer any of
those questions so again as you say
extraordinary times here we're going to
have to wait and see throughout the
course of Sunday if any of the two men
are going to publicly announce that they
will be running by Monday tomorrow 2 p.m
local time we will know for certain yeah
that's what I wanted to ask you about as
you say the pressure is on so what
exactly is the timeline I mean as as it
stands neither Boris Johnson or Rishi
sunak have officially declared they're
even running
absolutely and these are the two men as
you were saying there are the favorites
the front contenders the ones that
really it looks like it'll be one or the
other if you just go back to the
leadership race in the summer which is
coming out ahead of Liz truss also in
the debate that the two held he came out
in polling as people thinking that he
seemed to have a more solid grasp of
policies but when it came to the vote
and this is the conservative membership
vote
um he lost out to Liz trust and there is
a speculation that if it does go to the
conservative membership vote and just to
break it down for you if only one
candidate gets put forward then we will
know by tomorrow 2PM who the next prime
minister will be if two people or three
which could be potential but let's say
two for the sake of argument get put
forward Boris and Richards doing that um
then there'll be an online vote by the
end of the week from these members and
then we'll know by Friday who the Prime
Minister will be and there is
speculation that if it goes to that boat
then it could potentially actually the
Boris Johnson a lot of members of the
public also do not agree with that Boris
Johnson remains a hugely divisive figure
even within his own party so so many
question marks and we're just going to
have to wait and see how it all unfold
over the next 24-48 hours indeed okay
thank you for that update Stephanie
Decker there for us in London